[Music]
all right we got some requests here
let's do these real hate Conan it's my
birthday can I get a hug and a picture
let's do it picture here all right let's
go right here I hope you know him
why is there a sound effect okay I just
turned 50 can I get a birthday hug from
Brendan and Conan yeah from Panik I
don't know about Brendan he's gone so
that's like I like that it's Brendan in
big letters mining and Conan you can
barely read it I'll see you later
I don't know why yeah Brendan I'll see
you know I don't know I don't run things
around here Oh Conan I'm just doing
[Applause]
[Music]
Huff's Austrian fans you're from Austria
yeah you need an autograph is that what
you say yeah something I wanna graft
your sign and then I gotta go I really
gotta go I actually I don't have to go I
have nothing to do stay here
[Applause]
I'll meet you back at my house in an
hour no it's a really shitty house hey
thank you so much you guys were
absolutely spectacular
[Applause]
real women of film
[Applause]
[Music]
you